- Okay, I'm gonna give you a clue--
- Postman Pat's Christmas Special.
(Emilia makes the Toolman grunt)
That is the right person, right?
- Scooby-Doo.
- No!
Did you not grow up in my generation!
♪ Decorating the big pine tree. ♪
♪ Down in the den. ♪
♪ Glory hallelujah! ♪
♪ Christmas is here again. ♪
- "Is the movie corny? Often.
Is it moving in the most
basic, mor"- I can't do it,
"in the most basic moral way?
Every year we watch it."
- Every year we watch it...
- What movie?
- Uh, Love Actually?
(buzzer)
- No.
- Oh, I mean, that's the obvious choice.
- That's it guys, that's
gonna be his answer
to every single question.
(laughs)
Classic, classic moral tale.
- Oh, The Snowman.
(buzzer)
- No.
- For God's sake!
(laughing)
- That's an old one--
- The Snowman?
- No one's ever watched The Snowman!
- You are learning what
this man watches right here.
It's got "It's" at the
start of the name of the-
the name of the movie begins with 'It's'--
- It's A Wonderful Christmas.
It's A Wonderful Life!
(laughs)
- I am so glad that's on camera!
You are terrible.
Okay go on--
- What is it?
- I'm going to screw up this next bit,
"It's a Wonderful Life", yes!
- Oh my God, got it.
- Oh, youth is wasted on the wrong people!
- "Rent it on Christmas Eve
and give that 'Wonderful Life'
shit a rest for one year."
- Oh, Bad Santa?
(buzzer)
- No.
- Um...
- Uh, you're terrible at this game.
- I'm not, I'm better than you.
"Die Hard"?
It's right, isn't it?
Is it right?
- Moving on.
- Hey!
In your face!
- Damn it, you looked.
- Yippee ki yay, mother fucker.
- One of the Toolman's
best forays into film.
Toolman, okay, I'm going
to give you a clue.
- "Postman Pat's Christmas Special"
(Emilia makes the Toolman grunt)
That is the right person right?
- Scooby-Doo.
- No!
Did you not grow up in my generation!
The TV show that begins with,
(Emilia makes the Toolman grunt)
- Wha?
- Scooby-doo!
- And he had a really cute son,
he had like 4 sons and there's
the neighbor with the fence
and he's like "oh hey, how's it going"--
- Oh, yeah, "Home Improvement".
- Yeah, exactly, so who's
the lead actor in that?
- Uh, Tim...
- He did a Christmas Movie.
- Tim guy, Tim Curr, no
don't, yup, Tim dude.
- He did a Christmas
movie, what is it called?
- Oh My God, I do know this one.
I don't know the name though.
- Uh oh!
- Well what is Father
Christmas often known as?
What's he called?
- Claus, Santa Claus.
- Yeah, so put 'the' in front of that.
- "The Santa Clause".
- Well done!
- Hey!
- Look, I am lactose intolerant
and I am just about this close
to taking all those presents
back up the chimney with me.
- "Jolly yuletide cheer
with some cruel prank calls,
"sexual tension and
soriety girl slayings."
Am I saying that right?
- Yeah.
- Soriety?
- Um, soriety.
- Soriety.
- There you go,
that makes more sense in a
non-English accent, doesn't it.
- Yeah, in England.
- I'm from the sorority, I have a soror--
- (both) Sorority!
(laugh)
- We got there.
- You Americans.
- So English.
- Sorority girl.
I always wanted to be a sorority girl.
- When you say it in
that accent, now I know.
- Yeah, now it makes sense.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- [Interviewer] This is a horror film.
- This is a horror film?
- Hey, I didn't get any guesses!
- Thank you.
My girl's got me, she's on my side.
- It was made in 1974.
- It's a horror film?
- Yup.
- And it's a color of the
spectrum, color spectrum.
- "Black Christmas"?
- Oh my God, there you go.
- Hey hey!
- Good job.
(screaming)
- So it's just obviously that,
"Compared to part 2 it's
real close to 'Citizen Kane'.
I can't speak.
Scott Weinberg, E Film Critic
- There's only one Christmas movie--
- Oh come, on.
- Where the second--
- The most--
- The second movie is worse than the first
and that's "Home Alone".
- That's the only movie you can think of
where the second one is worse?
- Yup.
- The only one?
Am I right?
- You're right, you're right.
- Yay!
- Well done, well done,
we got him there guys,
we got him there.
- I might have looked at that earlier.
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
- How am I going to get this
out, yeah, I need some help.
- Brilliant.
(laughing)
- "The cheesiest thing
I've witnessed since
Lara Croft rode a shark to the
surface of the Mediterranean
(in a good way!)."
- Love Actually?
(buzzer)
- Nope.
One of the lines, you'll
get it if I say the line
"Smiling is my favorite"
and if you don't--
- "Elf".
- Oh my gosh, thank the Lord.
- You sit on a throne of lies.
- "The first Christmas
black comedy for children."
Oh, hold on--
- Home Alone?
- Yeah.
- Wasn't that?
- Well did we, yeah,
but it's different
reviews of the same thing.
We just glossed over the fact
that I got that immediately.
- Oh yeah, sorry.
(laughing)
- So I'm...
- It was more impressive--
- excellent.
- when I did it.
- Very good.
- But it was definitely
more impressive when I--
- Well it's just dull now--
- Because it was on your mind--
- How fucking great I am at this.
- It was on your mind, and
obviously, it sparked something.
- 65% on Rotten Tomatoes, "Home Alone".
- Outrageous.
- You need to change that up
- So if ours gets like, two--
Can everybody go back this Christmas--
- And becomes a Christmas classic--
- And put some more votes
on "Home Alone" please.
- Yeah, no, it's a good idea.
- Certified fresh. It has to be.
- Yeah, I mean "Home Alone 2" I get it,
but "Home Alone" 1, come on.
- Classic.
- With the iron?
(clanging and banging)
(screaming)
- That's my favorite bit,
it's me and my brother's favorite bit.
- The hot, the hot thing.
(sizzle noise)
Ahh!
(blowing)
(yelling)
- That's that.
- Amazing!
- Good job.
- We smashed it.
(theme song begins)
- Merry Christmas.
- Merry Christmas, bye.
Watch our movie!